[Evans] Let's define our procedure in the Python interpreter.
We'll give it the name measure_udacity,
and we'll give the parameter the name p.
Actually, we should probably give the parameter the name U, and we'll use an upper case U.
Not the most standard name for a parameter but appropriate in this case.
We'll introduce the variable count.
We'll set its initial value to 0.
We're going to use count to keep track of the number of strings that we found
that satisfy the udacity property.
And we'll use the for-loop to go through all of the elements in U.
Now we need to decide whether or not to count this element.
We can use an if statement to do this.
We're going to need to use a comparison to check if the first character of the string
is an upper case U.
If it is, we want to add 1 to the value of count.
If it's not, we do nothing.
So we use the equality test to check if the value at position 0 in e,
the current element of the list, is an upper case U.
If it is, we add 1 to count.
If not, we don't need to do anything, so we don't need an else clause.
And now we just need to return the value of count.
Let's test our procedure.
Our first example, the input strings were Dave, Sebastian, and Katy.
We see the result is 0, as expected.
We'll try the second example where we have 2 strings that start with the letter U
and see that we get the result 2 as the second value printed out.
We should also test a string that has a mix of Us and non-Us.
Now we're passing in 4 strings.
They all start with a U, but only 2 of them start with an upper case U.
So the result for the third number printed out should also be a 2.
And we see that we get the expected result.